SUPPORTED HILLARY CLINTON.
A LOT OF MY FRIENDS WORKED
FOR HER AND I WAS DEVASTATED
WHEN SHE LOST.
>> Tucker: TODAY'S IG REPORT
SAYS THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE
THAT POLITICS PLAYED A ROLE
IN JIM COMEY'S ACTIONS IN
2016.
AND THEY EXPECT YOU TO
BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE YOU ARE STUPID.
IT IS CLEAR A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN HIS LIFE WERE DEEPLY
HOSTILE TO DONALD TRUMP AND
NOW WE KNOW THE FBI WAS
FILLED WITH THE SAME KINDS
OF PEOPLE.
TODAY'S REPORT REVEALS EVEN
MORE TEXT MESSAGES TO AND
FROM PETER STRZOK AND HIS
GIFFORD LISA PAGE INCLUDING
THIS DAMNING EXCHANGE FROM
AUGUST OF 2016.
PAGE TEXTED STRZOK TRUMP IS
NEVER GOING TO BECOME
PRESIDENT, RIGHT?
STRZOK'S REPLY NO.
NO, HE WON'T.
WE WILL STOP IT.
STRZOK AND PAGE AREN'T ALONE
EITHER.
THANKS TO TODAY'S REPORT WE
KNOW ONE OTHER OFFICIAL WAS
ANTI-TRUMP IN OUTLOOK.
MARK STEYN IS AN AUTHOR AND
COLUMNIST WHO JOINS US
TONIGHT.
TWO FAVORITES.
THEY REVEAL SO MUCH ABOUT
THE UNDERLYING ASSUMPTIONS
OF THE FBI.
HERE I YOU HAVE PETER STRZOK
TO HIS GIRLFRIEND, QUOTE.
JUST WENT TO A SOUTHERN
VIRGINIA WALMART.
I COULD SMELL THE TRUMP
SUPPORT.
AND THEN THIS.
ON ELECTION NIGHT FROM AN
FBI EMPLOYEE.
TRUMP SUPPORTERS ARE ALL
POOR TO MIDDLE CLASS.
UNEDUCATED, LAZY PIECES OF
HUMAN FECES THAT THINK HE
WILL MAGICALLY GRANT THEM
JOBS FOR DOING NOTHING.
THEY PROBABLY DIDN'T WATCH
THE DEBATES.
AREN'T EDUCATED ON HIS
POLICIES AND STUPIDLY
WRAPPED UP IN HIS UNMERITED
ENTHUSIASM.
THESE FBI EMPLOYEES SEE
THEMSELVES LOOKING DOWN
RULING CLASS LOOKING DOWN AT
THE COUNTRY THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE SERVING.
>> WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU.
>> ABSOLUTELY EXTRAORDINARY.
THIS IS THE CHIEF OF THE FBI
COUNTER ESPIONAGE DIVISION
AND SOUNDS LIKE SOME RANTING
IDIOT.
AND WHAT'S INTERESTING TO ME
ABOUT THIS IS THAT THE BIAS
ONLY GOES ONE WAY.
YOU CAN BET IF THERE HAD
BEEN ONE SINGLE EMAIL ANY
FBI ARE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FIGURE SAYING OH,
YOU KNOW, I'M A BIT SICK OF
HILLARY.
I HOPE TRUMP WINS IN
NOVEMBER, THEY WOULD HAVE
PUT THAT.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
>> THERE ISN'T A SINGLE
EMAIL HERE FROM ANY OF THESE
SO-CALLED POLICEMEN
EXPRESSING ANYTHING OTHER
THAN NOT JUST THE NORMAL
PREFERENCE THAT PEOPLE HAVE
FOR DEMOCRATS OR
REPUBLICANS, BUT, IN FACT,
HYPER PARTISAN -- HYPER
PARTISAN FERVOUR THAT IS
ACTUALLY PREVENTING THEM
FROM ACTING AS POLICEMEN.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S
EXTRAORDINARY ABOUT IT I
FELL OFF MY CHAIR LAUGHING.
MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE, AS YOU
CAN SEE, I'M IN A FOREIGN
COUNTRY TONIGHT, TUCKER.
I'M NOT LIKE SEAN HANNITY
JUST HANGING OUT IN
SINGAPORE.
I'M IN AMERICA'S SWORN
ENEMY, THE DOMINION OF
CANADA AND COME DOWN AND
RELAUNCH THE WAR OF 1812.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: LOTS OF LUCK.
>> ME AND JUSTIN HAVE BEEN
PLANNING IT.
WE WERE SHOCKED BY THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT.
JUSTIN'S OTHER EYEBROW FELL
OFF AND HE SAYS WE HAVE GO
TO GOWN DOWN THERE AND BURN
THE WHITE HOUSE ALL AGAIN.
>> Tucker: IT'S GOING TO BE
A VERY TOUGH PILLOW FIGHT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
CHRISTOPHER WRAY TODAY AT
HIS PRESS PRESS CONFERENCE
WHEN HE WAS ASKED WHY WASN'T
HE FIRED?
PETER STRZOK SAID GOING TO
DO THIS BY THE BOOK.
WHAT THIS REPORT SHOWS IS
THAT THERE IS NO BOOK.
YOU HAVE THE DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI, WHO THINKS THAT HE IS
NOT ONLY THE INVESTIGATIVE
DETECTIVE, BUT HE IS ALSO
THE PROSECUTOR AND THE
JUDGE.
THAT'S NOT A SMALL MISTAKE.
THAT'S DEVASTATING.
THEN HAVE YOU PEOPLE LIKE --
PEOPLE LIKE STRZOK WHO
ARE -- WHO ARE INVESTIGATING
A CRIME.
THE CRIME OF DOING
GOVERNMENT WORK ON PERSONAL
EMAIL SERVERS.
AND THERE, EVEN AS THEY ARE
INVESTIGATING THAT, THEY ARE
DOING GOVERNMENT WORK ON
EMAIL SERVERS.
YOU HAVE THE MOST LAVISHLY
FUNDED POLICE AGENCY IN THE
WORLD, AND THE DIRECTOR IS
THE ONLY GUY IN WASHINGTON
WHO DOESN'T KNOW THAT
ANTHONY WEINER IS MARRIED TO
HUMA ABEDIN THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY EXTRAORDINARY.
THE REASON HE SITS ON THE
ANTHONY WEINER PEDOPHILE
LAPTOP FOR A MONTH IS THAT I
HAD NO IDEA SHE WAS MARRIED
TO HUMA ABEDIN IS IT WIDELY
KNOWN?
IS IT IN THE PAPERS?
THEY WERE MARRIED BY BILL
CLINTON.
YOU ARE THE FBI DIRECTOR.
THIS IS -- WHY DON'T YOU
JUST -- YOU KNOW, AS I SAID,
WE ARE GOING TO COME DOWN
AND RELAUNCH THE WAR OF
1212.
THEY SHOULD BE REDUCED TO
THE BUDGET OF SOME POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND THEN THEY
MIGHT BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE THE HUMA ABEDIN IS
MARRIED.
TO SAY.
>> Tucker: OUT GREAT MARK
STEYN IMPROVED EVEN BY YOUR